lebanon's hezbollah and its allies look
set to lose their parliamentary majority
that's according to preliminary results
from the first general election since
the country's economic collapse
voters took to the streets to celebrate
with supporters of opposition candidates
saying they hope to deal a blow to the
ruling politicians who they blame for
the crisis
turnout for the elections was low
our reporter rebecca ritters is in
beirut with the hezbollah bloc likely to
lose that majority what will the new
lebanese government look like rebecca
well but it's still a little bit too
early to be able to make any predictions
as you said yourself votes are still
trickling in but even after the votes
are all completely counted lebanon takes
is notorious for taking a very long time
to form governments so exactly how it
will look uh is hard to say at this
point but as you mentioned hezbollah
does look to be losing its parliamentary
majority that instead going to the
far-right christian lebanese forces uh
part of the so-called saudi us alliance
and they will be able to there may make
up an alliance a coalition government
they'll have to nominate a prime
minister who will then be able to form a
cabinet now that could take months so
lebanon has been known to be without a
government for two years at a time as
the sort of infighting and faction
behind behind the scenes faction
fighting goes on but what is clear and
what was really going into this election
one of the huge issues was the hezbollah
issue and it does appear that people
have voted with their feet many going
into this election saying hezbollah has
caused all the problems other people
saying that hezbollah isn't the only
problem in this country and we need to
deal with corruption on all levels but
people certainly voting with their feet
a lot of independent candidates also
winning seats we're looking at maybe 10
seats for the so-called change
opposition candidates and they'll play
an important role as you've got these
two opposing blocks the lebanese forces
on one side hezbollah on the other and
these independent candidates playing
quite an important role in the middle
okay whatever sort of coalition we get
and however long it takes what are
people expecting from the new government
because i bet the list is long
very long indeed uh the one word that
really could sum up going into this vote
was changed people really want to see a
change in this country it was the first
vote uh since the country's near
complete economic collapse and 80
percent of people in this country now
live below the poverty line the currency
has lost 90 percent of its value
the electricity is on for one hour a day
people have to survive with generators
but they can't afford fuel to run them
so people really living day to day and
they want change they're really fed up
most of the people i've spoken to said
uh you know that they weren't going to
vote for establishment parties now
obviously there are other people and
that's why the lebanese forces have come
out in front who believe that lebanese
forces were the only way to make change
because it was going to get hezbollah
out other people saying that isn't the
case but that is definitely what people
are calling for and it is does seem to
have been heard and heeded and you know
i think that the the new government
whichever form it takes is going to have
to listen to that
uh in the future of lebanese politics
rebecca why then such a poor turnout at
the polling booth
yeah that was quite surprising actually
and really disappointing here a lot of
people yesterday saying we just can't
believe it we were expecting such a high
turnout and especially with the diaspora
vote which was one week earlier and that
had a surprisingly high turnout with a
lot of people voting outside of lebanon
a lot more than in previous years but 41
of people came to the polls yesterday
and that's much lower than even the last
election which was nearly 50 so people
very disappointed uh there's a lot of
reasons one being that uh the sunni sect
uh really didn't have a candidate and
then they said that they were going to
sadhari who stepped out of lebanese
politics a few months ago
they said that they um were not going to
vote and of course you've got voter
apathy people saying that it's too
little too late we can't really make any
change there's many reasons for that low
voter turnout ben rebecca readers
foreign thank you